how you feeling cats hiding feel good
feels good
get back in there get back in the field
of reactions hey guys I'm Ryan alright
I'm cat Doss and this is Grayson this is
Grayson cat daus has returned to the
real rejects she hasn't been on since we
were like at 30,000 subs but she used to
come on frequently she got a little busy
yeah I was working on something she made
intercourse and now this has come out so
we're gonna watch our behavior a little
bit today she has a channel coming up
soon so subscribe to it now that way
when she has videos up she has a lot in
the pipeline so keep a lookout for it
but in the meantime this little family
reaction we got going on today we're
gonna check out the good dinosaur
official trailer number two now do you
understand any English yet Grayson Ryan
Ryan right can you say Ryan can you say
uncle Ryan Ryan wrote know Ryan right
upsets babies Ryan Ryan makes babies mad
that's where you're gonna learn
the dinosaurs
I think is mine just like being loved
right now I think we went far enough
today let's get you home
whoa
me to get home
they had a job for you keep on the dodge
and sidle up the loblolly past and
corneas
that creature protect you what is his
name
I don't know I'm done being scared I
think it although I have an excuse
that looks so adorable I've been waiting
for Pixar to do dinosaur movie ah that
looks so sweet would you be Grayson he's
gonna love it his favorite book is
actually his dinosaur book at home so
Jurassic Park no we don't have a
jurassic park book well you should
drastic park is meant for children's he
okay yeah he's okay
baby's pretty much constantly spitting
it up drooling something's coming out of
them at all time so just get used to it
heard of that before
see nothing's changed nothing's changed
nothing wrong I still treat you the same
that movie looks really adorable looks
really cute I at first I wasn't too on
board with the animals actually talking
to each other yeah but I wanted to like
more of a silent kind of film like
wall-e yeah but I I'm actually I'm
digging it I'm really digging it it
looks very adventurous it does and I
like the twist where the human is like
the dog yeah that's really cute I used
to be a like a preschool teacher and all
the kids who pretend to be puppies it
has a very children's vibe about it you
know like Pixar kind of I mean yeah
there's always that children's life to
it Pixar it's animation
yeah but I'm I'm watching this like this
feels more kid friendly than I'm used to
from Pixar yeah I think so in the sense
that this seems very much targeted for
children as well pick star films tend to
be an all-around family film like up
yeah
like up like there's some mature adult
themes and a lot of these Pixar stories
I don't I'm not really grasping that
here but it does seem like an
inspirational tale for young kids yeah
such as Grayson for when he grows up
he's gonna learn that if you're not
afraid you're not really living so
you've got to go against your fears
Grayson mmm-hmm I gotta go against your
fears just to grow up and be a dinosaur
you know yeah that's another way to do
it now Grayson remember there's a man
named Dick Grayson great hero of Gotham
City and blüdhaven and Robin Robin
Nightwing so people call me dick Ryan
totally different reasons but dick
Grayson's a good person you know I
imagine this move
was pitched how it's like Tarzan meets
Land Before Time oh my gosh you're right
that's how this movie was pitched I feel
it yeah that's the elevator pitched I
like and I ready for the twist the
dinosaurs are the people and the people
yes exactly yep I'm a I like the concept
of you know what would happen if the
meteor missed earth and the dinosaurs
still live could humans live amongst
dinosaurs so yeah I wish we got a world
where we can really explore something
like that oh yeah can humans and
dinosaurs live amongst each other I
think that would be really cute I think
that'd be really cute also somewhat
terrifying I'm pretty sure dinosaurs
would conquer us yeah or we would like
you know just you know they probably
want to have babies with us look at that
drool he's got like a bubble going on oh
yeah I he likes to have a little spit
beholder ah no no don't do it Ryan I
know but you know he hears these things
early on next thing you know he grows up
to be a pervert because he hung around
me too much it becomes like the next
friend it becomes the next Ryan right I
mean you're gonna get a lot of chicks
we're gonna reject you alright guys
that's it for today if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects kat das like we said has a
channel currently yeah but it's gonna be
in full fruition development - whatever
the word is you were looking for coming
very soon so subscribe now
so that way when her videos are up don't
get notified and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope let's do this shadow
Danny field say something interesting
hey hi ha so creative get rekt Disney on
a more serious note your videos are
great and so much effort gets put into
them I know this because I make short
films yeah that's it making trailer
reactions and YouTube video reactions is
just as much hard work as putting
together a short film and the editing
process is whoa can't say that around
the baby freakin genital slap female dog
anyway hopefully you see this and
consider checking out my channel keep up
the awesome reactions and pretty awesome
short films you do every now and then
dude thanks a lot Danny field
Thank You Danny okay let's do a look
like Danny field to give you this shout
out properly listen cat I don't know why
this keeps happening but so many of the
subscribers look like straight-up serial
killers well if you take the serial
killer yes photo does it mean come on
that's not the best angle just look at
it there's a total serial killer vibe to
this guy I wouldn't trust them around my
and dress them around Grayson he
kidnapped him hmm you see Grayson look
at this person that's a cannibal I know
cannibals make you dry if a cannibal
comes near you try to warn people
cannibals are near you
no no to cannibals I do understand him
you can't go on that website at this age
well he wants to go visit some certain
sites that I had bookmarked yeah not so
at least 18 or or until you're willing
to go against your mom's wishes